Maybe the thing you're most scared of is
exactly what you do.
Love what I do still have passion for
whatever it was.
I just tried to down there.
What'd you just say your name and tell
me what you do.
Uh,
I'm Chris Evans.
I'm an actor.
If you could give yourself advice,
like look back and,
and,
and talk to the 12 year old version of
yourself.
Yeah.
What advice would you give?
I'd say the sounds in my inmate might
seem okay oversimplified,
but it's profound.
I,
I'd say,
but a big thing for me,
you know,
it's so funny how noisy my brain is.
Everyone's praying,
it's noisy,
it's what it does,
it makes thoughts.
And the problem is,
I think in most of our lives of root of
suffering is following that brain noise
and listening to that brain noise and
actually identifying with it as if it's
who you are.
That's just the noise your brain makes,
you know?
And,
and more often than not,
it probably doesn't have much to say.
It's going to help you.
Mm.
For Captain America,
I read that you turned down the role a
number of times.
Can you just explain why it was because
it was a big commitment.
They wanted six movies and you know,
normally you do movies one at a time and
if one of those movies hits and his
success in your life noticeably changes,
you know,
your personal life,
your anonymity,
privacy is affected.
You have the opportunity to stop and
regroup and go home and just,
you know,
make a decision from then on how you
want to proceed with your life.
Worry was if this movie hits and there
is a lifestyle change and I don't react
well to it,
I don't have an opportunity,
the luxury to say,
you know,
guys,
I'm good.
I think I'm going to go back to doing
indies or maybe something else.
You know,
maybe in a couple of years I don't want
to act anymore.
I Dunno.
It's just six movies can be spread over
10 years and making a decision for a
decade and it's not just a decision for
you,
it's a lifestyle changes to a point
where your anonymity is compromised,
then it's really not your right to
complain anymore.
So if all of a sudden somebody in your
family ends up in a hospital and you're
going in and out and every day and
someone taking pictures of you,
when you complain,
everyone's going to say,
too bad you made this bed sleeping in
it.
And that's a shame and that's a decision
you have to make,
prepare for it.
This isn't,
this ripple effect isn't just going to
be about me.
And that's scary,
you know,
and you think,
well,
is there another way to get where I want
to get without this?
You know what I mean?
If you go with the strings attached or
six movies,
that's a scary loss of control that I
just wasn't ready to process them.
So I said no.
And uh,
I asked every human being in my life
what they thought and you know,
everyone said I should do the movie.
And um,
I did,
I said,
I've gone to therapy.
I went to therapy.
I was like,
fine,
I'll talk to,
I'm a therapist.
Who would they have to say?
And,
you know,
uh,
cause I do struggle with,
I get anxiety about certain things and
press and things like that.
It's,
you know,
all those things were tied into marvel
responsibilities and it kind of started
to shift on me.
It's,
it's,
it started to feel like maybe the thing
most scared of is exactly what you
should do.
Maybe this is actually what you should
push yourself into.
And it just started to make sense to me
that way.
And I said,
let's go for it.
And uh,
you know,
it was a bumpy acclimation.
It was certainly a nerve wracking first
couple weeks of shooting as to whether
or not I made the right choice.
But in retrospect it certainly was,
oh my God,
can you imagine him kicking myself?
And my agent's got
a lifetime supply and I told you since
off that one,
the Times that I felt my best are the
moments that I've been able to pull that
plug and say,
Chris,
Shh,
shh.
And it's not quitting.
It's not giving up.
It's not washing your hands of the
thought.
It's rising above it.
It's operating on a separate plane.
It's,
it's,
you can't dissect why that works because
of the reason it works doesn't speak the
same language that the brain speaks.
Can't try and say,
well why Shush?
Cause the shush is,
you know,
it's different,
it's different.
And when you just
just feels good,
you know,
like that's better,
that's better.
And I think back to all the time I've
probably spent suffering as a result of
brain noise,
hours of my life wasted.
So that's what I'd say.
Where are you from?
I'm from Boston.
You still consider that your home?
You said you were walking up there?
Yeah,
yeah.
I got a place back there.
I mean,
like I said,
I got nothing against that law.
I just prefer these coasts.
I'm one of six.
Uh,
I have three brothers and sisters,
the oldest sister and myself and younger
brother and younger sister.
We're really close now.
Very tight knit family.
We did everything together.
We're all actors,
so we're all very melodramatic and all
very young,
you know,
imaginative.
And we play a lot of games together just
in our backyard.
I had a great childhood.
I had a great youth and my family was a
big part of,
that's why I loved him,
but going home for me is kind of where I
just reconnect to that part of my mind,
you know?
And you just come out here for too long
and things that shouldn't matter.
Start mattering.
And Lisa recharge.
Initially I was really big into art,
drawing,
painting and art school is going to be a
path I was going to take.
I didn't start acting until I was about
maybe 1314 my older sister was doing
plays.
She was having a ball so you can,
I try it.
And it was a good time
because I kept doing it.
Probably had much bigger balls than I do
now.
Now I sit,
you know,
terrified before I additions.
I probably couldn't wait to get in the
room.
I mean,
I think back to some of the things I did
it,
you know,
acting camp and things like that.
Just the,
the Gusto,
the willingness.
God,
who led the yearbook?
Were you in the virtuous burglar or the
bald soprano that was in the virtue of
suburb.
And what role did you play?
I don't remember.
I mean,
I did a lot of plays.
I couldn't tell you that.
I mean,
I have nightmares about this.
Were you backstage?
And all of a sudden they're like,
all right,
we're doing the Virgin's book.
You get a call.
It took,
I don't remember my lines.
Just get out there.
They'll come to you and you've come out
onstage with a play you did 15 years ago
and you're forced.
This is,
this is what happens when I sleep back
in the good old days.
Good old days.
97 what a time.
Where did that change?
I mean,
when,
when did the anxiety starts hitting you
matters?
You know,
when you're like auditioning for,
you know,
for your work,
your career,
your life,
you know,
you're an adult.
It's not just fun and games.
You're actually trying to build
something and when it doesn't work out,
you start to kind of get,
you know,
so heady game acting,
for any movie you book,
there's probably right,
you know,
dozens of projections and that that can
play on you.
So you start to kind of put pressure on
yourself.
You know,
sometimes you go through stints of
having really good auditions,
really solid additions being like,
I'm good.
Every time I go in the room and I feel
centered and present and ready at the
times you're like,
man,
I feel like I forget how to act.
And then you're on shaky ground every
time you step in a room.
You said that there's a search to be in
the moment.
Does that only apply to acting?
It's everything that reality looks and
feels and smells and sounds like,
but you know it's not and,
and you're completely in control of that
unfolding.
And that's the time where I really feel
the most present.
And I think that's part of my addiction
to acting because I struggled to find
that in life.
It's a bit harder when there's no script
and this is just happening in a chaotic
form,
but the hunt for the moment,
you know,
the hunt to be present,
that's the goal.
You know what I mean?
Acting is like temporary artificial
substitute that it's like a drug.
It's great.
My goal in life is to find that to be
present like that in life.
It's hard.